if we want to continue uh fighting
battles hand grenades very important if
you use hand grenades please use vegan
grenades no animal should have to give
their life for all this Mayhem and Chaos
they have a special sticker on them you
really can't miss them in the uh grenade
Market or wherever you buy them yeah I
cover all of this and More in my newest
book Vegan Wars vegan Wars this video
had me going until the vegan grenades
and then I looked around and it's pretty
well labeled it says AI humor and even
though it says BBC and it's really good
I see you enemy this is a really good
deep fake it's not 100% of the way there
but it's I don't know 94 95% of the way
there enemy